-Whenever Donald Trump holds
a press conference,
his rambling,
nonsensical responses
raise more questions
than answers,
so we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right, Donald Trump
and the "Late Night" Press Corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go,
so without further ado,
it's time for
the "Late Night"
White House Press Conference.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Mr. President,
Mr. President, Mr. President.
Yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Mr. President,
if I had 100 bucks
for every time you lied,
what would happen?
-This whole room would be
filled up with $100 bills.
-What does it say
on your business cards?
-A horrible precedent.
-Why didn't Betsy DeVos
and her advisers show up
at your last meeting with
the Department of Education?
-They didn't know the location,
they didn't know the time,
they didn't know the year.
They didn't know anything.
-How are your kids doing?
-They're very good people.
I know many of them.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. President, can you recite
the entire alphabet?
-ABC, CBS, NBC.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. President,
what did you whisper
into Stormy Daniels' ear
when she got in your bed
that night?
-This is gonna be not good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I heard that Vladimir Putin
poked your tummy
and gave you a nickname.
What was it?
-Mr. Pillsbury.
-Sorry, just for clarity,
when did you file
for bankruptcy?
-30 years ago, 25 years ago,
10 years ago, 5 years ago.
-Wow.
That's a lot of, uh --
-Excuse me.
Excuse me.
-Oh. I'm sorry.
Go on.
-30 years ago.
36 years ago.
-Okay.
Moving on.
Level with me.
How much do you actually weigh?
-Five times more than
you ever thought possible.
[ Laughter ]
-I heard Mike Pompeo
was thinking
about opening a clock store.
What advice did you give him?
-I said, "Mike, don't get
into the time game."
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. President,
the Stormy Daniels scandal
has been quite a distraction
for you.
Are you done with porn stars?
-What do you mean?
I did like five today.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What happened
to all the cholesterol?
-I think I have it right here.
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
-President Trump, if I may
get serious for a moment,
why you still hustlin'?
-I still love the paper.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you say to yourself
in the mirror
every night before bed?
-They weren't laughing at me.
They were laughing with me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a nice --
That's a nice affirmation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What will it say
on your tombstone?
-A big, fat con job.
-Well, it looks like
we're out of time, everybody,
So on behalf of the rest
of the "Late Night" Press Corps,
have a good night.
We'll be right back
with Wanda Sykes, everybody.